(crowd cheering)
- Welcome back everybody.
This next very talented
singer was born in Oklahoma,
went on to become a K-pop superstar
then came back to the U.S.
to dominate American Song Contest in 2022.
Her latest single is called Sick.
Check it out wherever you get your music.
Everybody say hello to Alexa.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
- This is my favorite.
- Thank you very much.
- My makeup artist wears a black
one like that all the time.
And I'm like, you're so
chic, and what is that like?
- You know, I mean you,
you're chic, you're stunning.
- No, you're cool, you're cool.
Congratulations, once again..
- Thank you so much.
(crowd cheers)
on American Song Contest
and all your success that
has ensued that's so cool.
- Thank you.
- What was it like going back home
like after that big win
and then you've been on the road a lot.
- I, I have been on the road,
in the air, on the ocean,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Everywhere between.
- It was crazy though.
I mean, for one,
I still can't believe
that it even happened.
I mean, getting to meet, you know,
someone I've idolized my
whole life, Kelly Clarkson.
(crowd cheers)
- That was like,
that was like me with Snoop.
That was like me with Snoop.
[Alexa] Yeah, I was like, oh my God.
- I know, he was so fun.
And amazingly productive stoned.
(Alexa laughing)
Yeah, yeah.
I was like, "Wow, okay."
Uh, so what, so you're
from Oklahoma and I kept,
I remember hearing that
the first time on the show
and I was like, K-pop.
Where did the influence of that come from?
Like how long have you been into K-pop?
- I mean, you know, the
K in Oklahoma, K-pop.
- [Kelly] Totally.
- No.
- So much, it's a big thing there.
- It is, totally.
Now It is though, that's
the surprising thing.
- It's a big thing everywhere.
My nephew and niece are
obsessed and my children.
- [Alexa] Really!
- Yes, yeah.
- As they should be.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, so my mom is actually from Korea.
She was adopted when she was five.
So I really never had any like, you know.
- [Kelly] Aw.
- Yeah, that's me as a tiny, squishy baby.
- Tiny squishy baby.
- But I had no connection to my culture
or like the Korean, you know, language,
or anything growing up.
Like, not even joking.
The only connection I
had was a jar of kimchi
we always had in our fridge.
My mom and I always had,
does anyone like kimchi? Yeah? Okay.
- I dunno if I've ever tried it,
but you're like the third person
to bring kimchi up on the show.
And I'm like, how have I
never tried this? I love food.
- You should try it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
I would probably love
it, is it kind of like a,
it's not a sauerkraut thing, is it?
Like, it sits for a while?
- Similarish, it is fermented
like spicy cabbage, basically.
- Love, I would love it.
- You should try it,
you should try it.
- Yeah.
- [Alexa] I should bring a jar next time.
- I'm into all that, well,
you don't have to bring gifts.
You can just bring you.
- Well..
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- It's okay, you're enough.
- So when you spent a lot
of time in Korea, right?
- Yes, I've been living there
for the past six years now.
- So you love it then if you're
there that much, oh my gosh.
- I absolutely love it, yes.
- Yeah, what's your
favorite thing or what,
this is the thing that most
surprised you about it?
- Ooh, well, for one, like,
you know how like restaurants
and like bars close at like
2:00 AM 1:00 AM in America.
- Yeah.
- Korea, there's so much 24/7.
Like bars, cafes, restaurants, stores.
- Oh my God, did they
get anything done? Okay.
- We get so much done.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And that's the surprising thing.
Like we work, work, work, work, work.
Like Korea is very workaholic.
It's, it's a productive place to live.
But another thing that surprised me,
being from Oklahoma,
mosquitoes are a thing, yeah?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But the mosquitoes in
Korea are like massive.
- Really?
- Yeah, like, you know,
normal mosquitoes here are like that big.
- I can't stand mosquitoes.
- But the ones in Korea are like that big.
And like, if I'm laying down in bed
and I look at my ceiling,
I see when I'm like,
oh no, and I stand up and I..
- And I get attacked, it is
so funny, my daughter and I
will get, we will have a
thousand red bumps on us
and my son will not have one.
What does that mean?
- What blood type is he?
- I don't even, I should know.
- [Alexa] Because, from,
from what, you should know.
- I should know.
I'm sure it's on a card
in my wallet somewhere.
- 'Cause apparently mosquitoes,
like certain blood types.
- Well, they must love A
positive, 'cause that's what I am.
- A negative, so..
- [Kelly] Oh my God, it's bad.
- It is bad.
- Yeah.
They lied to me too when I moved to LA.
They were like, oh, it's
(mumbling), and the mosquitoes..
it's mosquito city, it is bad.
- They lied to you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They lied bad.
- Yeah.
This is what I did not know about K-pop.
I found out via my family, actually.
But they, there's storytelling in it.
So there's a whole like characters,
like four people in K-pop,
like, yes, you have a backstory.
That's what they do, that right?
- I do, yes.
- I love this.
- Well, great.
- I love imagery, so yeah.
- I mean most artists,
I mean you're a my favorite
person yourself, but,
yeah, K-pop itself is a very visual
and concept driven genre.
Dare I say for back of a
letter Word, letter word!
Oh my God!
- Better word, yeah.
- Back of a, back..
- Jet, jet lag, it's jet lag.
- Woo!
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Lack of a better word.
- Did you have some of
Bubles whiskey back there?
- I did not indulge,
but now I think I shall
when I go back, so.
But lack of a better word,
K-pop is a very visual conceptual genre.
So typically artists or groups
will debut with a concept.
Like they're like, oh, they're a bad boy.
Or they're like the refreshing
like school girl concept.
In my case, the team and I were discussing
what my debut concept should be.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We wanted to be original, innovative,
and we were like, oh, like
the cyberpunk AI concept
hasn't really been delved into yet.
So we went through that and
that had a whole trilogy
from debut up until my third
album release, Revolution.
And then we've kind of kept
the whole like cybernetic,
cyberpunk stuff woven
throughout the rest of my story.
- A little bit of AI in there.
- [Alexa] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Alexa] So yeah.
That's a cool concept.
- [Alexa] Thank you.
- Do y'all ever make like,
like mini like short films
with the stuff that y'all do?
'Cause that's a really good
idea, I have good ideas.
- She, she has Are you Listen..
- [Kelly] I'm just saying..
- CEO somewhere.
- That's a really good idea.
'Cause then you bought
into the whole thing.
I love the concept.
It's like Beyonce did that with Limited,
she did like a whole concept
album too with that, yeah.
It worked.
- It worked very well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Very well.
- But I feel like that's one
of the fun things about K-pop.
I mean, nowadays, of course
artists all across the globe
do very cinematic music
videos and storytelling.
But I feel like K-pop
kind of not originated,
but I guess K-pop really
made the cinematicness,
if that's a word, of music videos.
- We're making it a word, yeah.
- We are, it's very prevalent.
So like most music videos
will have a story, beginning,
middle, end, and like
after the song is over,
there's gonna be maybe even like a minute,
or two minute long clip at the end
to give more of a cinematic feel.
Like..
- [Kelly] yeah.
- It's just very fun.
- I love the storytelling of it.
So what, what about Sick?
The song you're doing today.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Yes, so.
- What's that about?
- We decided that this year 2024,
we're gonna expand to
the American audience
a bit more than Korea itself.
And I'm gonna be doing music
in English specifically.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So that's gonna be fun.
- That's cool, just to do both languages.
That's cool, yeah.
- And Sick itself, it
kind of tells the story
of like whenever you're
in love with someone
or maybe in a relationship with someone,
but you feel like
they're too good for you,
they're like out of your league.
Oh, you're so perfect, you make me sick.
Like that kind of..
- Yeah.
- [Alexa] Feeling.
- Oh, I like this.
- And we, do we know what we're talking?
- Yes.
- Have anybody felt that?
- I like this.
- Okay.
But..
- This is relatable.
- Personally, I interpret
it a different way
where it's like, same scenario,
but instead of you think they're perfect,
they're kind of full of themselves.
They think they're all
that and a bag of chips.
They're like, oh, I'm so perfect,
I'm so godly, blah, blah, blah.
And then you see that
and you're like, oof.
- [Kelly] That's not attractive.
- That makes me sick, so.
- Yeah, next, yeah.
- [Alexa] You know, it's the narrative.
- I love that too.
Yeah, I love that about
music and things in general.
You get, you take what you want from it.
I love that so much, well, we
need a quick commercial break,
but Alexa's new single is called Sick.
Y'all gotta check it out,
and she's performing it later on the show,
so stick around, we'll be right back.